藩内な音ズレ怜音3時時の歯が痛すぎて本当に多分皆さんだったら泣いてるぐらい痛
すぎて僕な方があったんですけど言いに行ってこれはヤバイのすぐハンド行かなきゃ
ねっていうことで今日なさ抜歯してきた抜いて今めちゃくちゃいい痛いんですけどいた
目のみでなんとか精神と思っている状態です反射場です皆さん回充電と思ってます
でしょ
か今回の動画とは全く別なんですけども絶対持ってた方がいいすよいつ何かが起きて
停電とかなんかわかんないで絶対に持っておいた方が良いと思いますそんな中こちらを
手に入れました
ドン懐中電灯アワーを只見で幼いますが一十百千饅頭まんじゅうマンるー年
ルーメンてー何に僕もわかりませんという女調べますよ
光の玉の単位とは簡単にの光の強さみたいなものらしいですね
光のタイのことをルーメンと言うらしいです明るければこれほどぶー名が高いなんか
この部屋のあたるさは出て150から200ぶー名が知る
で懐中電灯の一般的な明るさは200ルーメンラシーン
で10万て待って待って待って500倍
はこちらの10万ドルの開通鉄塔普通の懐中電灯の500倍の通風の開通テントらしい
ですはいってだけでも中身見ていきましょう
よろしくだけだけに行くよなんだが懐中電灯あればいいと言うんですけども
結局ね光が強いにこうしたことはないんですよねだってこれ1個でどんだけ見えるん
だろうっていう持ちの強い質問でしたが入ったが2階ちゃんとにこの2つ入るこ
トレジャーボックスのやつどんな月限定って感じですオープンプライス
pa
ユッカなってまってまってこのサイズ感やばいでしょ行くうわー
バッカーをのバッチこれ多いですよこれ恐ろしい回思うんですけどかっこよううーーは
発電所みたいになってますけど大丈夫ですかポリスて web 貿易を移って買いたい
ですねこれから外さ巾着やな
なーんか恐怖すら感じるぞの感じ以上中ネットで見た限りこれが史上最強の懐中電灯
らしいですよ
何
私ども首に掛けローとなるで一眼レフのようでそう
今度停電したらこれ持って移動します絶対
多いときのサブが活性しましたこれなんでしょうねなんか展示エコ充電や怖いですこれ
どう見てもさー
コンセントと2泣かないとできない奴じゃんああああああ考えてくるアワーお前は
大丈夫か緊急中はコンセントは使えないから困ってんだ
1回とやって世界最強のライトがどんなもんでちょっと試してみようと思いますだが
神々の聖杯並みの
基礎ありますけど服後黒字だ言ってもコレでも見にくいので服を白くしてくる q 中盤
掛け組て早速付けてみましょう
どうやってえっなにこれなにこれなにこれなんでヘアゴム入ってるの記念品みたいな
使うシーンですね
大
ano ん
[音楽]
大変枚と絶対的電池がありましたこれバッジ入ってんだったらつくんじゃないすかね
旅行行ったのが電源で動きますみたいな空気感出されてるはちょっと怖かったんです
けどこれつないでまずこれを充電しないと意味ないらしいです
me
あっあっあてぃパウダーでぽっちゃり系アティラのミラーぬーんっした困っ air
考えただけで仕事を覚えますよまあトイレなんですよねというわけでトイレのが惨め
カーミンしていきたいと思いますいいねめっちゃ聞かに反せず層はすごいめっちゃさせ
ですよ
ああああああっカチカチがこんなさんでしたな
dare
薄飛ぶために感じ感じん
こういったカブスいただけになってきたっ
[音楽]
とういうわけで完成しましたこの日に勉強あるんですけど壁をつくって全方向鏡の空間
を作り出しました
全方向カラーリングの空間が賛成しましたのずう前はっているころでしょうないとに
戻りましょうというわけで鏡の部屋を作っている間にたば充電が終わりましたそもそも
この内でも地下時代僕も昨年でどれほどのものなんかちょっと知りたいところではあり
ます
me
来た来た来た入るだけで完成しました甲虫ないが前回最強10万ルーメンの光を持つ
懐中電灯です
初夏匹を頭につけてみます
[音楽]
金井
だこわいっつかないんだけど合わないんだけどなんで何がゆえのえっ
まっつあってはないと思うんですけどですろっつうこうでしょうって作って
めっちゃ強くつけてはこれで
ええわいブリブリ無意味がわからきたか調べる限りグロスの塗りすぎとかが原因って
書いてあったんですねこれもそうすれば彼のではないのでしょうか
わからんけどよしいきます
ブーブーっ夏だけですよ
まあません a
マッパ
明るやばこれ
a やばいうん世界が世界を卒が一つくれ
[拍手]
今ちょうどや辛さですねたぶんこれが普通の懐中電灯くらいなんですよねやっぱすごい
と本物なんでこれじゃあ本物が何か分からんですけど何ここにちゃんとに表記がある
目線は何ルーメンでてるかって言えば700lm なんで結構できることですねって
殺すと
これ以外は max ですかねここ男わかりますこれ強さちょっとわからないと思うよ
これすごいて本当にも世界の崩壊してるは辛すぎて
危険危険じゃないけどすごい少ないでやっては仮にちょっと気外で試してみましょう
はいというわけで俺んちの前なんですけどももう真っ暗なんですよこの状況で即ライト
をつけてみようと思いますきます行きますと言ってますよ
ウルーモス
もうやばい
ヤバいじゃなかっ
a やばいやば am 2パンっ
自治体荒野をしたいっ
くらい車
位と思った
ってよくないの
4 o
はいというわけで10万10年世界さあっつも体の圧痛的でも世界最強のライトの光量
の強さは完全にわかったんですけども俺をさらに生かすために私このヘアせめて鏡に
なってる部屋をつくりましたもう
はクビでしょすだちこの部屋このすべてが神と部屋で正解
生協の懐中電灯の光を当てると10万宮面と光が反射反射反射反射反射反射反射
ガチャガチャじゃね
あっはぁもう
太陽ができるわけですそう私機を家に太陽を作ろうと思います
思いますが私の理論が正しい食べ対応できると思うんですよ10万ルーメン普通に車の
ハイビームより強い光がホのツイーサなトイレの一角で反射しまくったらもう光が
集まった詰まってとんでもないことになるのかなと思いまして私今日は私は今日対応を
創る紙
アポロンになろうと思いますみなさん今私のことをあぽろんとお呼びください
[音楽]
で来国光よではいってきますもう本当にねマジで俺頑張って作ったからさぁもあらゆる
方向はマジで得られる方法が完全に鏡の穴横のヘアー were a
さしまってしまいました良い一発ちょんちょちょっと来いいやーそれ
10万組の8つけてみようと思いますまつげに対応即制するとダメなんで私速
サングラスをかけさせていただいております危ないと思うんで職種はしないようにして
くださいそもそもこれしないようにしてくださいボタンはどうかわかんないんですよ
見つけましたではイケナイ太陽誕生で3
っていう1
これまで弱い方ですね
おい
goo
ふえぇ
英霊までちょっちょ伝わるからねーっ
ぶーぶーっ
めっちゃグリと思うけどこんなかじゃあスゴめっちゃ幻想的なキラキラした嫌になって
ません
いやすごいすごいすごい
めちゃ曲綺麗ですがたまんねぇ本当に幻想的な空間が出来てると思いますよ
あれ
というわけで大大失敗
[音楽]
ええええええ
uh
me
car
あっはぁ